[Applaudissements]
alors
sans que vous allez voir que certains
sont sortis de pousser des ailes ont
voulu fêter avec la victoire en prenant
de la hauteur et surtout en prenant
quelques risques qu'on a eu très peur
regardez avec le lampadaire regardez
heureusement voilà on va voir d'autres
d'autres images vous allez dire après si
vous ce que vous en pensez partout dans
toutes les villes de France et une scène
de l'Est des scènes de joie les français
d'origine marocaine des Marocains ont
bulés dans toutes les grandes villes
pour fêter la victoire regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on va voir ce qui a fait alors non
je veux juste montrer la police
française qui se réjouit du résultat qui
fête la victoire avec des supporters
regardez ça c'était une belle image
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y en a eu il y a un petit peu partout
en France a commencé sur les
Champs-Elysées regarde
[Musique]
excusez-moi pour les petits soucis de
réseau ça peut arriver malheureusement
qu'au niveau du réseau ça coupe par
moment
alors
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez Gilles
Verdez vous n'êtes pas choqué pas du
tout c'est une formidable liesse
populaire et on confond on dit il y a
des incidents oui il y a quelques
incidents isolés à Nice effectivement il
y a eu un transport en commun qui n'a
pas peur justement on va voir regarder
il y a eu à Lille et à Nice on va voir
Lille d'abord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va voir
alors donc oui quelques incidents mais
la fierté la fierté et la joie du peuple
marocain et c'est pas parce qu'on
brandit un drapeau marocain qu'on aime
pas la France les gens confondent c'est
la fierté de ses origines c'est parce
que on est content donc moi je trouve
que les Marocains ont été exemplaires je
leur dis bravo qui continuent à fêter ça
j'espère pour eux voilà il y a quelques
incidents mais ça ne doit pas gâcher la
fête Cyril qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé
super bien passé sur les
Champs-Élysées
c'est c'est les premières c'est la
première fois que je les vois j'imagine
qu'il y en a eu et on va pas les on va
pas dire non c'est triste mais le plus
important c'est les images qu'on voit
c'est que la plupart des personnes ils
sont heureux heureuse et c'est faut déjà
aussi pour le Maroc c'est historique
c'est moi c'était sympathique vous avez
juste ah oui moi j'ai kiffé et je suis
rentré chez moi j'étais fatigué parce
que j'ai tout donné et je pars chez
continuer ma vie normale et vous
monsieur j'ai suivi le match à la maison
tellement j'ai stressé je voulais pas le
voir avec les gens pour vous dire la
deuxième mi-temps j'ai éteint la télé
enfin j'ai mis bébé TV pour ma fille de
8 mois je voulais pas regarder ce que
mon fils il est venu m'a dit bah en
train de gagner 2-0 et tir au but après
je suis sorti grâce à un ami à sa Night
et la salle que je remercie avec la
taupe que je remercie ils ont fait une
belle soirée dans un restaurant
très belle soirée un bon repas avec des
beaux drapeaux partout et on a bien
rigolé très très bien très très bien
passé donc c'était voilà je le vois avec
vous hein ce que je vois alors sur les
réseaux voilà il y a par exemple Bruno
Retailleau qui a dit pourquoi les scènes
de liesse au Maroc ne donnent pas lieu à
des dégradations comme en France
simplement parce que nous acceptons
depuis des années d'être des paillassons
d'accueil des gens qui s'essuient les
pieds sur notre pays en toute impunité
immédiate évidemment dans toute les
célébrations dans toutes les scènes
chanter la Marseillaise ça va la mémoire
ça part en barrigoule parce que non
enfin en tout cas on était on est super
content pour vous on vous adore et voilà
il y a une poignée qui vient gâcher la
fête qui vient donner du gras en moudre
excusez-moi qui vient donner du gras à
moudre justement parce que moi aussi
j'ai lu plein de choses très
désagréables sur les réseaux sociaux
parce qu'il s'empare évidemment parce
que quand on lit tous les comptes rendus
rodéo urbain ils font quand même des des
la fête mais près des commissariats pour
attiser la il y a plein de choses qui se
passe qui sont pas agréables c'est aussi
à la marge mais ça donne du grain moudre
et ça m'énerve ça ne me choque pas ça
m'énerve que rien
gâche la fête et donne une mauvaise
image je suis désolé c'est dommage parce
que c'est à la marge mais voilà
profitent de ces moments-là il faut
amplifier le truc sur un petit
pourcentage alors que si vous voulez
dans les restaurants filmés ce qu'on a
vécu moi hier ou ce qu'il a vécu
monsieur hier ou d'autres points par
exemple moi mes parents ils sont au
Maroc on s'est appelé en FaceTime ils
m'ont montré Rabat pour montrer les rues
c'était comme vous avez dit il y a pas
de débordements il y a rien après il y a
toujours une minorité qui va prendre des
gilets jaunes qui va prendre n'importe
quoi pour faire ce qu'ils ont à faire et
après c'est l'éducation on va faire quoi
de ça on peut pas les nous-même les
prendre et leur dire arrête tu es en
train de nous salir une image en colère
on peut pas éduquer tout le monde
Géraldine ouais franchement c'était un
match moi j'étais à titre personnel très
très très heureuse ma maman ma mère est
au Maroc en ce moment elle me dit que la
fête était absolument incroyable là-bas
effectivement là-bas il y a eu zéro
débordement donc on a beau quand même
dire qu'il y a zéro débordement là-bas
et pourquoi il y en aurait ici on peut
pas se réjouir de ça on va dire que
c'est une fatalité même s'il y en a très
peu même s'il y a une minorité
globalement les célébrations elle était
magnifique elles étaient joyeuses elles
étaient familiales elles étaient
festives moi je vois pas pourquoi je
devrais me résoudre aujourd'hui qu'en
France il y ait des débordements je vois
pas pourquoi on caillasse les flics je
sais pas pourquoi on met le feu à des à
du mobilier urbain voilà je me réjouis
c'est surtout pas mal de foot c'est quoi
alors en fait c'est quoi le jeu
politique parce que ça s'est passé au
Pays-Bas ça s'est passé en Belgique ça
se passe en France donc pourquoi à votre
avis pourquoi alors il y a une
signification politique à ça il a
récupéré politique
sur la façade de l'Hôtel de Ville
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
politique ça par exemple de faire ça à
votre avis
c'est une provocation de comme je vous
ai dit D1 2% ou les médias ils aiment
aller sur eux et après ça fait ce qu'on
ce qu'on a des gens disent que ça c'est
hyper bien passé sur les champs
au Maroc du Maroc j'y suis allé c'était
très festif très agréable très sympa
vraiment la fête moi j'ai rien vu de mal
hein franchement c'était très très bien
passé le mois les gens m'ont dit qu'ils
ont vu des trucs mal et deux c'est toi
ministère de l'Intérieur la police est
sur les dents en attendant
éventuellement qu'il y a un match France
- Maroc ouais bah c'est sûr
la France gagne vendredi et le Maroc
gagne samedi parce que là ça va être la
fête bon bien sûr
préparer après sauf qu'il y aura ces
événements là ça eux de faire les
structures compétente pour sortir France
Maroc moi je suis pas bon après tout est
possible c'est 11 hommes contre 11
hommes tout est possible il reste trois
matchs vous préférez quoi Maroc
Angleterre moi j'aurais préféré baroque
France mais c'est ce qu'il va y avoir je
pense pas en anglais
il peut avoir au Maroc l'Angleterre on
les voit comme ça mais attention
[Applaudissements]
les vieux celui-là
je pense que c'était aussi beaucoup de
bruit pour rien
c'est à dire que c'est vrai que sur les
réseaux ça c'est emballé etc exactement
au Canada aller sur Google et regarder
les liens si hier au Canada magnifique
et pourquoi en Europe
la question c'est pas ça c'est pas que
au Maroc ou que c'est pas que quand le
Maroc gagne
ou moi je peux vous rappeler en 2018
quand la France a gagné contre
l'Argentine par exemple en Coupe du
Monde il y a eu des dégradations aussi
exactement donc c'est pas que quand il y
a un club un pays africain qui gagne
bien sûr que le le peuple africain se
voilà et se révolte entre guillemets je
pense pas que ça soit de la politique je
pense que plus c'est des des des des
enfants qui exactement parce ils sont
pas politiciens à la base c'est les
médias qui récupèrent ce discours
d'enfants qui sont rien du tout ils
savent même pas ce que c'est la
politique qu'est-ce que c'est de poser
un drapeau sur une mairie quels sont les
enjeux donc les médias ils se focalisent
sur eux et après ça fait une image de
ses enfants
c'était les spectateurs s'il vous plaît
merci oui oui ou pas oui
à 80 % les gens sont choqués par ces
images et non avant pour ça alors on
voit beaucoup disent pas choquer on en a
pas eu de choquer vraiment donc voilà
pour représentez pas le public
je sais pas parce que en vrai quand on
voit enfin des gens qui sont ensemble
dans la joie on a envie de dire c'est
super bien sûr quand il y a des
débordements et après il y a des feux
des choses comme ça et ça crie et Machin
et les gens ils arrivent pas à dormir et
les enfants ça leur fait peur et tout ça
parce qu'il y a trop de voilà quand il y
a des débordements et ben là ça devient
négatif donc une piscine